- But speaking of acting,
so I asked your brother
this once, but you and...
You and he were in one of the
Harry Potter movies, right?
- That is correct.
We were in the first one.
- Just so you know,
there will never be anything you do
that is cooler than this to me.
I'm like, I think this is
the coolest thing ever.
- You are not alone.
- That is crazy.
- The coolest thing.
- That would be my claim
to fame till I died.
Like, I love Harry Potter.
I love the whole...
I read all the books and
then I saw all the movies.
I love the whole world.
I think it's so creative.
- Same thing.
I had just read all of the books.
And then like, I was
going to school in London
at a performing arts school.
And they came to our school
and were like, "We're doing this movie,
but we can't tell you what it is."
We all auditioned and stuff.
And then they told us
it was "Harry Potter."
And I remember...
I clearly was American
because I was like, "Can
I audition for Hermoin?
- Hermoin? It's Hermione.
Very American.
I heard that you had a
crush on Daniel Radcliffe.
Is that true?
- Oh, for sure.
I was 11.
We were in Gloucestershire
shooting a scene
and it was Valentine's Day.
And I actually got him a beanie
baby and tried to like...
It was Valentino.
Wrote him a love note.
Don't know if he ever got it.
I think I've told this
story a couple times
but in fact, I actually saw
Emma Watson the other day
and I walked up to her
and I was like, "Hey.
We've met a few times but I
don't know if you know this,
I was in Harry Potter."
She's like, "I remember you."
I was like, "You absolutely
don't remember me."
I was in extra.
- Maybe she's got one of those memories.
- She was being kind.
- I will say though,
you're one of those striking people though
and it's a lot to do
with your eyes, ma'am.
So once you meet you,
your eyes just stand out,
especially when you're that blonde.
So it's like, I don't know.
She might've remembered.
You're very striking.
- You're very kind, too.
- Just saying.
No, I'm just saying,
you remember somethings sometimes.